Mexico
well frankly just like China when it
comes to Mexico I'd be pretty I'd be the
strongest president on Mexico okay I
would only try to interact with Mexico
in a very positive level I would never
try and do anything that could frankly
be seen as not positive but you have
people there coming across the border
they're raping they're killing and
frankly frankly truthfully we have an
obesity epidemic we've got a problem a
horrible problem you and I we've got a
horrible problem with obesity have you
been to Taco Bell
they don't have anything frankly
underneath 2000 calories on their menu
you go there they bring in their Taco
Bell they're bringing their food over
contributing to the obesity epidemic and
we're supposed to I will get on the
phone with the CEO at Chipotle a Taco
Bell all those places frankly as they
take my calls they'd say I love I'll
don't get me wrong
I love Mexican food so much they call me
the Mexican they called me the Mexican
vacuum I eat so much Mexican food they
call me they say they say here comes a
Mexican vacuum that's the nickname they
gave to me is the mess
right yes well frankly listen I just
said Mexican vacuum you asked me the
question I said Mexican vacuum because
that's what they called me over their
selves in the book when it comes to the
physical fence okay I would build a wall
so great it would make the Wall of China
frankly look like peanuts it would
frankly look like a joke appeared in the
wall and I'm going to make the Mexicans
pay for it I'm gonna make the Mexicans
pay for it I'm going to make them weed
wagget I'm going to make
well frankly that's a conversation I
would have to have and it's a
conversation that I would have
truthfully in a very positive way
because they respect me frankly I have
so much money involved with Mexican
cartels and companies that they would
say hey Trump's they would take my calls
so it would need to take place with a
call and we would talk about this and we
would Fred then and that frankly at the
end of it we would there would be no
more problems believe me there would be
no more problems with Mexico Mexico
would take my calls
they'd take my calls click here to hear
me talk more about foreign policy at war
I frankly I'm not a fan of war